there's a whole bunch of stuff I want to
cover I also want to ask you know as we
kind of move into all these different
topics how did you meet Andrew and
Tristan
okay so for years ago I had a job on in
Romania and I didn't know anyone in
Romania and I knew them through social
media I contacted them they helped out
with some connections and as I said more
is I mean it was genuine but it was a
bit of a throwaway comment I said I've
got a weapons and uh tactics training
company in Ukraine yeah I would like to
host you guys just as you know a gesture
instantly Andrew said okay when all
right and then he battered me like okay
when okay when I go in like is it a man
of action right and so we hope that um
it was meant to be three days you know
with some footage and good training not
yippee shooting or you know practical
training and I put aside 2000 rounds we
went through 8 000 rounds and I know
you're a guy who enjoys the rounds uh
enjoys the range that's a lot of rounds
for three days there's a lot of lead to
put down range exactly it was 12 hours a
day that's still Dawn we weren't
sleeping much there was Heavy drinking I
I realized at that time these guys are
built different and also the way they
learned that mix of physical and mental
ability in fact they just didn't get
tired that's when I realized that they
were something different and then at the
end of the three days it was Tristan's
birthday and we're sitting in a cigar
lounge in a hotel in Kiev and as I'm
sure you appreciate there's a lot of
distraction here you know three
able-bodied men typically wouldn't spend
an evening sitting talking together for
six hours they'd be out doing other
things right but we just sat there
together and talked and that's when they
started sharing their insights into The
Human Condition into society and it was
really apparent to me that and I said it
at the time that they have a leadership
role to play in humanity and in
masculinity and I said back then
anything I can do in my Global Network
you know my particular set of skills for
a long career anything that I can add to
you know the movement that you guys are
doing then I'm all in and I've been all
in ever since
uh you know I've messaged Andrew for a
few years now I've got him on WhatsApp I
was talking the other day and um
you know one of the things that I
brought up before he blew up on social
media I saw it coming you know I saw
I saw those
um viral clips that were being made they
were they were they were being produced
in the hundreds probably almost on a
maybe maybe daily could have been a
weekly basis you know match but there
was a lot of Clips coming out and I said
them at the time
um because I just had him on for a
podcast I think it was around the time
you dealt with that culty issue
um and I thought that was interesting
how he how he dominated that scenario
that was that was definitely a plane to
win episode that's still on the podcast
by the way you guys can go back and find
it I said to him I go you know who do
you look towards as a mentor
um you know who do you lean on at first
he thought you know I was talking about
kickboxing and he named the uh coach but
but I was talking more along the lines
of because every top shelf guy always
has a network of people that he can lean
on to offer guidance to be a sober
second thinker if you're cooking up some
idea that may not work you know usually
often ask you know your inner circle
what they think of it
um and then that's when he introduced me
to you he said you know you should talk
to Jewel you know he's a bit of a fan
you know he helped him out with
something that I can't remember what it
was at the time or maybe you know you
can talk about it but
um
it sounds like he's relied on you for
quite a while
that was that was four years ago you did
the whole Kiev shooting thing with him
uh five years now five yeah I mean I
don't know about relied upon it takes
take like some people out there saying
I'm Tate's manager hang out with Tate
nobody manages tape my goodness Mission
Impossible I was going to ask you why
are you are you in fact his manager
because that's a rumor that's going
around I'm not his manager and I pity
the fool who tries to be his manager
like Tate has such Clarity of Mind such
frame such
um conviction in what he does I I I I
would I don't no one can manage tape
let's put it that way Tate is tape can
you manage himself
yeah you can he was pretty conscious um
you know quite quite the stress Edition
quite the chess player um I do have a
relationship with Tate which I think is
a bit unique like he and I will have
pretty heated discussions if we disagree
on something of course I'm respectful
about it I do view him as the most
impressive all-round man I've ever met
so of course are very respectful but
also with my background in Risk
um I'm often the guy who's playing you
know Mr worst case scenario this could
happen that could happen and I'm often
putting that forward now sometimes he
listens to my counsel sometimes he
doesn't but I wouldn't say he relies on
me I think he he appreciates my input
and at the end of the day he's the CEO
of his own brand he's going to do what
he's going to do so that's our
relationship then in terms of my input
to how he does what he does does he have
a gag order on him right now he can't
speak to the uh public or he can't speak
publicly yeah I'm not sure entirely I'm
not read in with the legal team again
I'm his mate I'm not not his manager or
not part of you know the pr or legal
teams which I do know exists obviously
um from what I understand
he's he's and I said this earlier um
he's examining the chessboard right now
it's a very complex situation
and he's the sort of guy he's not going
to rush into making any moves so I do
believe that he is allowed to do what he
wants but also
I mean
if I was trying to put a man in
put a man away then I'd be wanting him
to make mistakes right I think that's
what the opposition if you will is
thinking and he's very cognizant of that
fact so he's very he's being very
careful not to make mistakes so I
believe he can say whatever he wants
whenever he wants but he's assessing
that chest but it's the mid game right
it's a very complex game many many
different factors involved uh so as I
understand he's assessing the situation
and when the time is right he'll make
that make that decision to go though
you know it's interesting I'm I've never
met Andrew or Tristan
um they've extended it invites to do
rallies with them in the past
um it was mostly during the covert
period when travel was a bit of a pain
in the ass but
um they seem like good lads they strike
me as good men that are good at being
men
um I think Andrew in particular is funny
um he's articulate he's smart Tristan's
a bit more of a Playboy he's a little
more a little bit more of a joker you
know of the two I think but I think
they're both good guys and the funny
thing is is you know whenever I post
anything like there's no pictures of me
and Andrew together anywhere but people
think that you know he's my pal that I'm
part of his group that
um
you know people say things like
here's here's actually what I get a lot
of I get a lot of the kids posting the
promotional in my timeline on
Twitter you know especially and I also
get the guys that are like oh you guys
are Pals why do you associate with him
you know he's a low life piece of uh POS
blah blah blah both of these people get
blocked by the way they're
I have no time for either one of them on
my timeline but what what are they
really like with the time that you spent
with them in the five years are they
those guys are they Comics are they
gentlemen are they or are they these you
know misogynist men that uh abuse and
take advantage of women
indeed so first of all there's
definitely a Persona that you see with
Andrew but it is
he is he's an Entertainer and he knows
how to turn it up
how much how much of that is
entertainment though like you remember
those cartoons like the Johnny Bravo you
know cartoons where it's like you know
you take a a 10 you turn up to like 17.
how much of that is really him versus
him acting you know when you get all
those
Clips it's a good question I I
at the end of the day he's a very
brilliant man and a brilliant men
through our history have always been
very complex
um I think it was uh Patrick David who
spoke about take in that context so to
put in the exact figure on that's always
going to be difficult um what I can say
is the tape behind closed doors you know
around women around his family around
his brothers incredibly respectful
complete emotional control never once
seen him angry never even seen him raise
his voice he's very calm very logical
very rational and also very respectful
that's the real thing so the idea that
he's some you know Monster is simply not
real and you'll notice everyone in his
inner circle came out immediately when
they saw these allegations said hang on
we've been around this guy that's not
real that's not who he is
um he definitely has
um a drive to make noise and create that
that
I mean he's mastered the attention
economy right he knows how to bring in
attention better than anybody else in
the last 10 years easily
but I think the key point is people
trying to say that what he said is
therefore evidence of a crime
if that's the case every gangster rapper
ever needs to go to prison you know
every every shock
um
all the female you know musicians I uh
you know I drugged them and I stole his
money you know all of that stuff I think
that one actually was literal
I believe most of them are literal in
fact you know you know what I found was
really impressive you know they locked
him up in his brother in the in the two
gals and I would assume that their
strategy would have been okay the women
will fold first so we'll lock them up
we'll apply a little bit of pressure
we'll let him go we'll bring him back a
little bit of push pill standard stuff
but they never seem to strike a deal
with them that would allow them to
charge the two brothers with anything I
found that impressive that they had
those two women loyal to him loyal to
them that entire period of time
and I think that speaks to two things
one they take care of their people like
they're good men they're good giving men
and two the truth is the truth
it really is like what has come out if
people look at this objectively and the
two main complaints that their their
credibility is shot that they are on
record saying hey let's take this story
to Netflix
if journalists want to actually be
journalists and look at the verified
leaks that have come out showing the
conversation between the two women they
are conspiring to do this again I'm not
a legal professional I'm not ready
non-legal it matters but just from
seeing what's come out objectively the
credibility of the source of people the
main people making is allegations is
shot it's not there it's proven to be
you know not real so in that sense
uh the whole thing is I think to sum up
Tate is a very good man and everyone
who's actually met him knows that he's
very respectful very calm he's not
capable nor is there any logical
reasoning why you do such things if
you're flying private all the time and
pushing a Bugatti why do you need to and
do you have the time or energy to
exploit some women to make small amounts
of money online on tick tock on whatever
platforms it's just not real and that's
why everyone on this team and Tate
himself knows that he will be found
innocent because the truth is the truth
logic will prevail it's just a matter of
the the process playing itself out
what do you say to the folks that assess
his
um rapid rise in Fame and wealth I mean
um I mean I've lived in North America
for the vast majority of my life I spent
a little bit of time in the UK but uh
I've dealt with lots and lots and lots
of entrepreneurs and part of trade
organizations entrepreneurs work sort of
stuff he made a lot of money very very
quickly and a lot of people have you
know asked questions about that it's
raised eyebrows right you know because
something like what is it 30 or 27
supercars in a Bugatti you normally
wouldn't take a few years what do you
say to those guys
I think there's some basic maths that
will help and also if you have fifty
dollars you can verify this so his
platform the real world for as I
understand it has over 100 000
subscribers with a very high recurring
rate and the tales of victory that come
out of that are huge so let's take a
hundred thousand let you talk about this
too you know since you're on the topic
of the real world as well okay uh 100
000 members times fifty dollars a month
do the math again that's verifiable you
can join up and see the active members
yourself so as to where the money came
from that's one I also know he was very
active in making very courageous Moves
In in crypto early on so that's another
and
the man has this undying energy and
undying workload again I've been around
some pretty high profile people myself
he doesn't stop working ever like it's
just everyday Conquest he wakes up angry
he doesn't eat until five or six pm
because when he's hungry his brain's
clearer like everything about that man
is driven towards conquest and it's not
a surprise to me at all you've got the
intellect you've got this undying work
ethic you've got the support network
both with his brothers his brother his
blood brother and you know the warm
around you and you've got this just
unending desire for Conquest I mean the
man is a work machine so I don't view it
as a quick rise I don't view it as
surprising and I think if you if you're
able to build a platform that has well
over a hundred thousand people I think
it's it may be or it did hit 200 000
people with a very high resub rate you
know retention rate there's obviously
value there the man knows how to bring
in attention and add value to people's
lives and that that's how you make money
if you can get attention and then
monetize that attention and add value to
the lives of the people who follow you
you're going to do well so all this this
accusation is about criminal this and
that I'm the guy who he talks to about
his risk decisions he is hyper aware of
not doing anything criminal because he
knows that would undo all of the legal
stuff the the Halal way that he makes
money improving people's lives would all
be undercut should he do anything
illegal he's very conscious of that so
there's nothing illegal there and if
there was I wouldn't associate him
associate myself with him very simple
I've got a life I've got a family you
know I wouldn't be around him if he was
doing anything illegal I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out